As we begin now looking
at how to evaluate
various machine learning algorithms,
let's start back with KNN and
look a little more closely at
the sorts of solutions it provides.
Let's start with our training data,
and remember we've got pairs of X and
Y, so each one of these dots
represents one training tuple.
And I'm just making this data up,
of course.
But suppose we were going to query
this KNN model over in this region.
Say right here at this point.
Well, the nearest three.
Let's use K=3 here.
The nearest three are going to be these.
And remember,
we take the mean of their value to
get the value at that query point.
So if we query from here
all the way to about here,
our model is going to take
the mean y value of those,
so the output of our model is
going to look something like this.
And notice it gives the same
value at all these points.
Eventually, as we query from left
to right, we get to a point where
this one gets dropped out,
and this one gets added in.
And at that point we'll have a sudden
drop about like that in the model.
And we continue on like this.
We'll have another drop like that.
If we query our model now
from left to right in very,
very tiny increments we'll get the
result that looks something like this.
Note that indeed there
are sort of jump points here.
Some nice things about this are that
it's not over fitting the data.
In other words,
it's not tagging each point.
A negative aspect though is at
the ends there we have these
horizontal lines that are no longer
changing or essentially this
model is not able to extrapolate like
we might if we had a parametric model.